what's going on guys so I haven't done a
discussion video for a while and I
really kind of miss it I just want to do
a laid-back discussion video on
something that is very relevant right
now I'm not going to do too much editing
to this video I want to make it more
real and just kind of like hey this is
me and these are my thoughts there's a
lot of talk right now around the YouTube
community about fair use fair use is
essentially you can use copyrighted
material in regards to satire parody
criticism commentary or education and
that's where you know maybe you're
making a video or a website post or
you're you're writing something and you
might want to include some photos or
maybe some brief clips to support what
you're saying but the problem is larger
channels and smaller channels here on
YouTube are getting very adversely
affected by copyright claims copyright
strikes and some of them have even
gotten their channels removed without
actually knowing what's happening I hate
everything is a channel that I follow
and I spoke directly with Alex the owner
of said YouTube channel and he still has
no idea why his entire channel got
deleted for a day his channel was
flagged for aggressive spamming or
something like that and his channel
eventually got restored but that's
basically because he has a large enough
channel to actually make an outcry about
it
which is sad because the same thing
happened with Doug Walker who I've met
and is a super nice guy I talked with
him often and I'm privileged to know him
because he was one of my initial
inspirations back in the day to want to
turn on a camera and start talking about
movies and he got a copyright strike on
his channel for a studio ghibli video
that he had made and he didn't have
monetization or the ability to upload a
video longer than 15 minutes for
something like three weeks but he
continued to make videos and the only
reason that his channels monetization
and that strike got removed was
essentially because he made a video
finally saying hey youtube
what's up with this and because of his
large numbers on his channel the outcry
was loud enough for YouTube to hear and
fix the problem so there are two
problems there
for in my mind for one obviously the
problem is there's these unwarranted
claims and strikes going around the
other problem is that YouTube only
changed and helped fix these issues for
both of those channels because they were
big enough to make a public outcry and
that's the worst situation in my mind
because there's tons of smaller channels
out there that have the exact same
problem who have gotten their channels
removed who have got entire videos
removed for no real reason other than
someone somewhere said hey use one of my
pictures or hey you used five seconds of
my movie bye-bye sorry or we want all of
your money because you know you use a
little bit of our stuff fair use is very
very easy to understand it's not that
hard to understand there are tons of
websites out there that can really
educate you on the subject and even
YouTube has gone out of their way to
make it very clear and as well as
supporting people through various fair
use protection programs and even
instigating a plan last year to
reinstate money to youtubers who had
lost money while illegitimate claims
were filed which is a really great thing
because the main issue I think is that
there really is no penalty for filing a
false claim you can sit there all day
and flag people's videos and try to make
money off other people's videos and if
someone were to file a claim on one of
your videos you can dispute said claim
but then there's a 30-day period where
they can just wait if they really want
to and they could honestly wait to day
30 and go you're right this is a
fraudulent claim this is fair use I'm
going to remove said claim but they just
made money off of you for a month and
they don't have to give that money away
that is a big problem now I've been
doing a lot of research over the past
few days on the way the community feels
about this and the overall vibe I'm
getting is that smaller youtubers who
run smaller channels are upset that they
don't really have a say and that bigger
youtubers are getting preferential
treatment and I can understand that you
want to know why because
I started with zero just like everyone
else I have a lot of subscribers now and
trust me I'm very grateful for that I've
made that clear in every single video I
make but I started with zero I've been a
youtuber with 10 15 subscribers going oh
my god I just got 10 subscribers oh my
god I just got a hundred subscribers I
know all about that
I started almost 7 years ago so I still
today as recently as a few weeks ago
fight off fraudulent copyright claims I
would say in the past 7 years I would
estimate I've gotten at least 40 to 50
which is really not cool because I've
never ever broken YouTube's Terms and
regulations in regards to uploading a
full complete movie if I if I discuss a
film or I talk about a movie and I show
like if I say for instance Casino Royale
and I say well you know the opening
parkour sequence is really great and I
show you five seconds of James Bond
jumping off of something and then just
cuts back to me talking about it that's
perfectly fine anyone will tell you that
and that is been my most recent huge
fight was my Casino Royale review I got
a copyright claim on that by MGM they
said that it had some footage of theirs
in there which it does but it's also a
very long video in which I discussed the
film so I replied simply by saying look
I apologize if I've I literally wrote
this I was like I apologize if I've
offended MGM because you can dispute
that claim and I said I'm an accredited
member of the press in Cleveland Ohio
I'm a certified film critic on Rotten
Tomatoes this is clearly a review in
which I discussed the film from a
criticism
standpoint I use very brief moments of
said film and three weeks later after I
had to directly contact my YouTube
network who is someone who knows people
in YouTube emailed them finally YouTube
was like oh sorry yeah well
of the claim are bad and MGM you know
remove the claim but that was three
weeks of monetization that MGM made off
of me
because they wanted to despite the fact
that I gave Casino Royale and a plus and
I said basically everyone on earth
should check that film out because it's
one of the best Bond films ever made if
not the best and I'm just like sitting
here wondering what's that what is that
all about now look it's easy to look at
that and say well you're only concerned
about this because you didn't make some
money again not true when I started
YouTube in 2009 it wasn't like today
today you can instantly monetize your
videos you can say YouTube I want to
monetize my videos and they can approve
you back in the day it wasn't like that
you had to apply for partnership which
would then allow you to monetize your
videos and allow you to create
thumbnails for your videos and back then
I made my videos virtually literally for
free for like two years I think two to
two and a half years I can't remember
the exact date when I got partnership
but I believe it was about two years it
could have been two and a half years
please don't quote me on that cuz I
might be wrong but it's definitely at
least two years that I did that for free
and during that time period I received
many copyright claims because I would
show a little bit of trailer footage
throughout my review I used to do that
for all my new releases I would show a
little bit of trailer footage you can
still see some of my older videos still
have that trailer footage and believe me
still to this day I get random copyright
claims on my amazing spider-man trailer
review from like 2012 or 2011 or
something and I'm like great
and sometimes the video that I get
claims on doesn't even have any
copyright footage and I watched this old
video and it has no pictures or nothing
and I'm like what are you claiming here
with the thumbnail and it's really nuts
because it's not just myself obviously
tons of bigger youtubers and tons of
smaller youtubers especially smaller
youtubers are going through this and
believe me I understand what that's like
because I
has been the person who has 100
subscribers who has a video that he
worked hard on who gets a claim on it
and you're like but what's the purpose
of this what is really the goal of doing
that to somebody well the the main
problem that I have with this is that it
limits creativity one of my favorite
things about YouTube is that it's taught
so many people how to be creative I have
seen so many young people so excited
about the fact that they can be creative
that maybe they had a really crappy day
at school or they had a really crappy
day at work but they can come home and
create something and the fact that
YouTube is allowing these bigger Studios
to kind of hoard over people who are
really excited about creating content
when they're really not doing anything
legally wrong that's a big problem
no yes if you're you know just using
someone else's music throughout the
entirety of your video or you're just
uploading footage of something well
maybe diffusing the image or blurring
part of it or maybe flipping it making
it a mirror image of then obviously you
know that's wrong but if you're just
creating some content and you feel like
you're adding some comedic value or your
content is transformative in that it
alters or changes or add something new
to said content and you're getting
crapped on for that that is a huge
problem it's not just the money aspect
that is very important though why in the
world would you want to work hard on
something that you deserve to earn
something for and then have some
faceless person out there at some studio
sitting behind a computer make money off
of you obviously that is not a good
thing but the larger issue is just about
the fact that I'm seeing content
creators get stepped on and it bothers
me because I am a content creator I I
see comments I see comments okay I see
people look at my channel and they say
well Chris Tuchman this Chris Tuchman
daddy has 600,000 subscribers or
whatever and he doesn't have to worry
about it
guys it's not true yes I have found some
success doing what I what I love talking
about film but it's not like I just woke
up and had this I still deal with
copyright claims every few weeks and
I've dealt with them for the past seven
years there isn't a day that goes by
it's something Doug said in this video
there's no day that goes by when I feel
like maybe I shouldn't use that one
picture I don't know you know there
isn't a day that goes by where that
where that feeling isn't there but I
shouldn't have that feeling because I
know what I'm doing is legal so look my
whole goal with this video is to
hopefully just help continue to raise
awareness for this issue and this isn't
a problem that is just now starting it's
been going on for many years the only
reason I haven't really discussed it is
because well to be completely honest
it's a it's a scary topic it's a scary
topic and sometimes it's hard to wonder
when the right time is to really raise
some awareness for something and other
people have already taken that first
step and I'm just coming in and saying I
agree clearly some changes need to be
instituted and I think the most
important one would be some penalties
for false claims because anyone can go
around and claim a video and it's just
not right and I also want to let you
guys know that I appreciate that you
understand where I'm coming from because
it's easy to to look at somebody and
just see a number well you know
so-and-so has 300,000 subscribers
so-and-so has 800 thousand subscribers
so-and-so has 80 subscribers and reduce
said individual to a number don't do
that because that's what studios do
that's exactly what studios are doing
they're looking at people who have
larger followings and thinking oh well
we better we better back away from them
because they have larger followings and
they're just seeing a number and they
attack smaller youtubers because they
see a smaller number so don't look at
someone and just say well this person
clearly doesn't deal with issues
he has a larger following because
clearly if anything out of this hashtag
WTF you thing has made us aware of is
that everybody on YouTube right now is
dealing with this no matter what no
matter how many subscribers you have and
changes need to be made guys thank you
for watching this video definitely check
out Doug's video a lot of other people
are making very good videos about this
and I think the best thing that's come
out of this is the fact that virtually
every youtuber is on the same side
because we're all affected there isn't
an issue here that divides us everyone
on YouTube who is trying to be creative
who is trying to create content is
affected by this and again this doesn't
mean that we can just go out there and
upload music and videos and things from
copyrighted material you know with with
no repercussions what it does mean
though is that we should be able to be
creative and that we should be able to
follow the law the fair use law and it's
important to educate yourself on that
law and not just think well I can just
upload whatever I want because fair use
not always true definitely educate
yourself on the actual law there's tons
of material out there directly from the
government and YouTube that you can read
that can really help you understand said
law but the most important thing I would
like you to take away from this video is
that being creative is a great thing
it's what I love I love watching films I
love watching well-made videos I love
reading good books or looking at great
art because these are people who are
being creative who are creating content
who are really allowing themselves to
shine through their art or their
material and that is something that
should never be hindered it's a
beautiful beautiful thing and it's one
of my favorite things on this entire
planet whenever I witness anyone
discovering a passion for being creative
and it truly it truly is so inspiring to
me so please don't lose that creativity
if you're afraid of fair use learn about
it educate yourself on it it's very
simple and easy to learn guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stubborn eyes